foreign
[Music]
anime here however I do think it's good
to be able to switch it up a bit once in
a while instead of going through the
more popular stuff I'm going to dedicate
this video to giving recommendations for
action anime that I feel deserve a
little bit more love these are the shows
that probably have a thing or two that
held them back from breaking out and
becoming more mainstream and popular so
for this edition of the list I've got 10
titles but I'm not going to be ranking
them since it's too subjective let's not
waste any more time then and let's get
the show going anyone heard about alter
a record of battles
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I mean we've got made in Abyss Gamers
classroom of the elite and kakegurui but
not much that became too mainstream one
show they still managed to get buried
underneath all of them it's alter a
record of battles however it's quite
easy to see why it seems that
military-themed anime just isn't
something that becomes too mainstream
unless there's an extremely notable or
charismatic element to it like Saga of
Tanya alter on the other hand actually
sets its focus on something that we
don't see too often in military anime
the behind the scenes the tactics the
economics the politics behind it all
it's something that people don't seem
too receptive to but nonetheless it's
interesting definitely not something
you'd see every day in the realm of
historical fiction it's more a tactical
approach to the whole idea of warfare
and if you're someone who's up for a
different take to the military and War
genres following the adventures of two
Grill Marmot could be something that you
could try
foreign
Torah is up next
[Music]
we've been used to seeing a lot of old
classics being reimagined and modernized
these days but it seems as if they
weren't as common back then or maybe
it's just a result of the remade titles
being not as popular those days with the
exception of Hunter Hunter one such
example is ushio and Torah the 2015
remake of an early 90s anime it's not
the first time we've seen the story of a
boy protagonist being forced to work
with a supernatural being that may or
may not be hostile we've seen this type
of dynamic in stuff like parasite for
example but all in all ushio and Torah
does relish in the good old traditional
Japanese culture aesthetic it does feel
like a spiritual ancestor or inspiration
to shows like Inuyasha or natsume's book
of friends it's a pretty straightforward
show and the start off with a monster of
the week Fair before the real plot kicks
in however it does have its moments and
I think that it's a show that's Shonen
fans might enjoy
following that is neura Rise of the
Yokai Clan
carrying some similar Vibes to ushio and
Torah is nura Rise of the Yokai Clan
nura however does share some
similarities with Hitman Reborn where
the focus is on the protagonist's clan
and their stories that are entwined with
them the show may seem a little plain at
first but it's overall a very enjoying
watch once you get to know much of the
characters starting to care for them
thanks to their Charming personalities
and root for them as they fight various
threats to both the human world and the
existence of the nura clan and trust me
there's a lot of them in the two seasons
of the show's run the show is a great
watch but one major thing I can say that
holds it back is How It Ends on a major
Cliffhanger with no anime continuation
in sight it means that you just have to
jump off and go read the Manga at some
point but you know what the Journey's
worth it in my opinion
[Music]
circus follows and it's another show you
might enjoy
hero Fujita if you did your Googling in
the middle of the video you'll know that
this guy is the creator of ushio and
Torah which we just featured a few
moments ago just like the other title
garakuri circus brings a lot of the old
school violence and the vibrant
Expressions that the Creator is known
for instead of going down the
supernatural route garakuri circus takes
a more modern approach instead
integrating its battles with dolls and
puppets giving a distinct style that
blends battle Shonen with a mild science
Vibe it's probably something like
unbreakable machine doll yet another
show that got buried in the hype of
seasonal counterparts and in this case
predominantly killer kill The annotation
got mixed to mostly negative reactions
from the fans which could be a huge
reason as to why he got buried in the
Blockbuster season featuring bunny girl
Senpai Goblin Slayer slime alicization
and Zombieland Saga while it may not
hold a candle to the mentioned shows in
terms of popularity garakali circus
ended up being one of the enjoyable side
watches that I did have at that time
it's a sidewatch for a reason though but
I did have fun with it in spite of them
cutting a lot of stuff from the manga
what I feel is a very strong anime even
taking the changed or cut content into
account is the ambition of Oda nobuna
understandably the idea of gender-bent
historical figures in an anime series
raises some eyebrows yeah there's fate
but a lot of these types of shows
typically ended up leaving no cultural
footprint at all being relegated to fan
service fests which pivot into the
reputation these gender-bench shows got
generalized into the ambition of Oda
nobuna is a show that does little to
disprove that stereotype it actively
relishes and the sexy has a pervy main
character in an isakai before the genre
boomed and those tropes became
scrutinized and has a pretty pragmatic
approach in adapting Source material but
deep within all of that is a diamond in
the rough you see while Noble Knight
does play around with the fan service it
also contains a pretty engaging story
about both Warfare history and the
budding relationship between our
protagonist and the gender bent Warlords
of the sengoku era The Last Arc the one
with the most changes from The Source
material in fact feels better to see in
what the anime did due to the payoff and
the climactic feel it gives in terms of
the hero's relationship with Noble
Knight and the gank still it's got that
curse of having an insane Cliffhanger
ending plus it aired in the same season
as the first Sao so it's a case of wrong
place wrong time not that it would
explode in popularity in a weaker season
given its genre and the amount of
relatively Tamer fan service compared to
actual etchy shows
I flew under the radar like this one
then don't forget to hit the like button
and share the video it's my way of
seeing which content you like and which
areas to focus on so let your voice be
heard through the views and likes we
resume with the most recent show to be
featured so far world's finest assassin
foreign
titles are a dime a dozen and have
practically taken over the anime world
the genres also garnered a not so
Stellar reputation and the big titles
often find themselves in some sort of
controversy with mushoku tensei being
one of the starkest examples of that
however though in the same season that
featured the second part of mushoku
tensei is this isakai title that Elise
tries to spice things up a little bit
world's finest assassin looks to provide
an isakai experience with some creative
changes gone was the loser otaku
protagonist and the quest to save the
world and in comes the grizzled Assassin
task to defeat the previous hero in this
fantasy world in spite of several titles
attempts to spice up the isakai formula
with some twists with the premise they
often fall into the same trappings of
the genre eventually for world's finest
assassin I think it succeeds in skirting
those trappings to some extent sure
you've got the controversial themes the
Betrayed cynical protag Trope and
overpowered protagonist the Harem
atmosphere but they're all done in a
less upfront and more mute good way than
a lot of isakai it becomes even more
amazing when you recall that the guy
behind this is the one who made the
mimetic redo of gila compared to the
latter this thing's a masterpiece and
the same could be said when putting it
alongside half the random issakai titles
out there
now if you wonder what other creators
have been up to I present to you you the
10 deities
it feels fitting to follow up redo of
healer guy's Creation with this other
underrated action show this time from
the guys who brought us gobayashi-san an
inter-species reviewers with those
titles on their resume I'm pretty sure
you know where this one's headed and
true to form either 10 deities makes no
effort in hiding its fan service still I
think the show has some pretty good
content once you get past those sketchy
elements good content that got buried in
the relatively weak summer 2021 season 8
of 10 deities has been criticized as an
over-the-top and edgy show that's full
of style over substance while I won't be
refuting those claims what's to say that
these kinds of insane fight animations
over-the-top power scaling and high
attention fights are actually bad I mean
at the end of the day it just means that
the anime appeals to a certain Niche and
that certain Niche would definitely
enjoy this storied history of the war
between demons and either 10. all in all
you can clearly see the love put into
adapting these series with its
incredible production values and I'm
positive the anime team know what
they're doing and who this show is made
for still it doesn't help for its
building popularity if there is any it
also doesn't help that it aired
alongside goboyashi's son ironic as it
may be if you're the type who's always
raring to watch a show that goes in your
face with the pretty visuals eye-popping
fights and a dash of fan service this
one could be the show for you
[Music]
however if you're up for the more
artistic side of things in the
traditional sense perhaps you can try
vampire in the garden
[Applause]
Sarah
the Netflix model is something that I've
often criticized in my videos I don't
have empirical data for this but I
really think that one of the best things
when watching anime is the weekly weight
and the community discussions that come
with it immediately dumping stuff in one
go for a binge model may be appealing
for some but come on have you ever seen
engagement for something like Stone
ocean vampire in the garden I feel
forced victim to the same model because
I do feel that the show has what it
takes to be a cult classic vampire in
the garden strongest suit comes in its
production values with Studio witch and
IG at the helm that much is to be
expected and the art really shows it
comes with an engaging story that while
isn't unique does the job well enough
without being too dragging or Too Short
of course vampire in the garden caps are
being cult classic level never breaking
the glass ceiling of being a mainstream
anime the overall Vibes the not so
unique premise and all that makes it
something that feels like it's better
done as a movie that doesn't sound bad
by any means and if you want a title to
relive the good old medieval fantasy era
of the 2000s then you should definitely
check it out we found that one up now
with super Crooks
[Music]
of course we lead a Netflix title into
another one don't we super Crooks
released in late 2021 looks to provide
the anime medium a representative for
the edgy superhero-like titles that the
West always had in its pocket the
superhero genre isn't new to anime by
any means there's really something
unique in the overall feel that super
Crux gives then again it's a series by
the guy from Marvel who brought us
things like Kick-Ass so everything makes
much more sense now super Crux takes us
to a vibrant world of superheroes and
super villains hardly a unique premise I
know but I found myself growing in dear
to the characters as the show went on
they're charismatic in their own ways
and their Dynamic together is a joy to
watch they really fit so well in this
world that the Creator came up with and
the same goes for their role in this
story that quickly rushes into Full
Throttle I really enjoyed this show it's
not groundbreaking in terms of anti-hero
superhero shows or High shows but it
does bring a different flavor to it if
you will something unique Western yet
works so well in anime form
foreign
I'm at number 10 already alright then
let's end it with Rage of Bahamut
Genesis
games has become a multimedia Juggernaut
in the modern Days Grand blue fantasy
princess connect shadowverse Idol Master
list just goes on with a Stranglehold
over the market in mobile games it's
inevitable that some lesser known titles
get sent to the Wayside one such
franchise under its umbrella is Rage of
Bahamut which is a shame because said
franchise came with a pretty damn good
anime razor Bahamut is set in a world
that very obviously serves as the
predecessor to what Psy games Fantasy
games ended up looking like high fantasy
settings with Humanity being caught up
in a war between Gods demons dragons and
all the other creatures from these kinds
of Worlds kind of like Final Fantasy I
guess however while it's easy for the
Rage of Baja month anime to be a
soulless commercial for cygames Mobile
card games which never really made it
big overseas it's surprisingly great at
building a world and increasing the
stakes to make us all Care by the time
the big Showdown comes there's a lot of
great fighting and exploration and
generally a lot that looks cool thanks
to the creative designs and animation
that made this my surprise of the full
2014 C season in fact I think the game
actually did the anime A disservice by
being completely dated for mobile game
standards back then closing off
potential avenues for the Rage of Bahama
the franchise to become more mainstream
thanks to that most people probably only
have one passing knowledge of Rage Obama
thanks to shadowverse and Grand blue
universe but the original Psy Games IP
that grand Annie of them all if you will
has a really great anime that a lot of
people seem to have missed out on
oh
[Music]
with 10 shows under our belt which one
of those is your favorite I'd love to
know your reasons so do tell me in the
comments oh and share some action shows
that you think are underrated while
you're at it too and we could feature
them in a future video if this one does
well thank you for watching and I hope
you enjoyed the video I'm looking
forward to seeing you again in the next
video as we'll have a lot more cool ones
coming your way